[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings jesse
smallett continues testifying this
morning at his criminal trial in chicago
the former empire actor is charged with
six felony counts of disorderly conduct
he's accused of filing a false police
report claiming he was the victim of a
hate crime attack in 2019. charlie demar
is outside chicago's cook county
courthouse charlie good morning
vlad good morning so far jesse smallett
has spent about six hours on the stand
for one of those hours smolette was
questioned by prosecutors about why he
didn't cooperate with certain parts of
the investigation smolette also denies
claims made by the osendaro brothers who
testified last week that they were paid
to carry out the attack now legal
experts they are torn on whether or not
the defense made the right move on
putting smilet on the stand
jessie smallett is trying to convince
jurors he did not stage a violent hate
crime on himself on the stance millet
who was black and gay said that he and
abel osindaro were friends he said they
did drugs together and had a sexual
relationship you ready to tell your
truth i'm ready to do what i got to do
yeah yeah tell the truth not my truth in
court osandaro told the jury that smilet
wrote him a check for 3 500 for a
workout program and for helping to stage
the attack smilet denied that claim
testifying that the check was for
nutrition and training advice when
describing the attacks millet said it
felt like someone massive coming up to
me not enough time to think when asked
why he didn't notify police smilet said
i'm a black man in america i don't trust
police
police entered smolette's downtown
apartment on the night of the attack in
response to a 9-1-1 call from someone
who said they worked for the actor
smelled as seen on police body camera
video in a red and white sweater with
the rope around his neck
there's a bleach
the brothers abel and ola osindaro were
initially identified as the attackers
and arrested smallett was also arrested
and within weeks he was charged with
staging the crime but the charges were
dropped by state's attorney kim fox a
special prosecutor later assigned to the
case charged smilette with six counts of
felony disorderly conduct first staging
and lying to police about the attack
smellette telling the jury there was no
hoax it is a terribly high risk for
justice millet to take the witness stand
cbs news legal analyst ricky clemen says
that smilet created an unnecessary
burden of proof by testifying in his own
defense what happens psychologically is
the jury forgets about the prosecution
witnesses and when they go out
what they assess
is do they believe justice millet or
don't think
today prosecutors will finish
cross-examining smilet this case could
be in the jury's hands as soon as
tonight now some lettuce pleaded not
guilty to six counts and if convicted he
could serve up to three years in prison
nate
charlie thank you high-profile actor
high-profile trial
and introducing new facts
it just causes a little bit more
confusion always curious when a
defendant takes a witness stand right
and they say it's always risky but
listen he's sticking with his story the
nigerian brothers are sticking with
their story somebody ain't telling the
truth so it'll be up to the jury to
decide he said i'm not telling
my brother they came in yeah that's true
that's true interesting to see how this
all turns out